i would say that feminism has played a
big part in that like it i think the
feminist movement probably started out
really great and those intentions were
wonderful with getting equal voting
rights and
all of that but it's gone too far and
one of the quotes from your book that i
love says femininity is undervalued
feminism doesn't seek to make women
better or more feminine feminism seeks
to make women into terrible versions of
men
and i talk a lot about masculine and
feminine on this podcast so what is the
healthy feminine look like to you
well
you know there's like the green flag
side of things and like the red flags
green lights red lights you know sort of
thing
i find it easier to
help guys when i'm dealing with them you
know more specifically on what to avoid
so what not to do
um so i think that if you start with
that for the most part you're not going
to invite a tremendous amount of chaos
into your life
um so i tend to approach things that way
that's why i have a chapter in my book
on red flags to avoid with women sort of
thing
um
so if you want to talk about that stuff
we can get into things like that
yeah i loved the red flag and actually
some of them were a little uh hard to
hear because i'm like yo that's me and
that's me
um
how do you deal with that
um
i i sit with it and i'm like okay why
does that trigger me a little bit like
what what is he saying when you talk
about women that have tattoos
um
i can i can see
why that would be a red flag especially
for men who are trying to find a
feminine woman like
um
because i mean you've got the tats you
got the boss [ __ ] thing you got the
single mom thing
yeah so but going into the dating thing
so once i got divorced going into the
dating thing i was i was like i'm i'm
the woman i know what i want i'm you
know
i'm the boss i don't need a man
well then i was only attracting betas
and that wasn't what i wanted so i had
to i had to figure out how how to trust
a man to be the masculine give him the
space to be the masculine and step back
and fall into my feminine and that's
when i found a masculine man who doesn't
put up with my [ __ ]
and that's exactly the kind of man that
i i wanted um
but nobody tells us that they tell us
take care of yourself and don't depend
on a man you know all of the
toxic [ __ ] sorry i should turn off my
ringer
and actually the audio clipped for about
four seconds there you and i lost our
connection so i didn't hear what you
said so
probably probably go back about 10
seconds and let's re-record that part
okay um sorry let me just turn off this
ringer so it doesn't go off again
[Music]
i i think there's just some there's so
many contradicting
ideas out there when they tell women to
be independent and self-sufficient and
then we don't
need a man at all and it completely
eliminates them from our space but we
want a man and we only end up getting
the wounded or the betas and that's not
who they should be in their best form
either
i would agree yeah the sexual
marketplace is very messed up there's
there's a lot of weak men there's few
strong men
there's strong men that have a difficult
time you know maintaining strength and
frame in relationships because men
because women
inherently test a man's frame to see how
strong it is and if he's competent
enough and
that's what often puts guys through the
process of beta testations for a
thousand concessions so it's very very
difficult out there to maintain a
long-term relationship i've i've had
loads of conversations with guys that
are that are looking to move from dating
to long-term relationships and i always
saw them
if you haven't mastered dating like if
you don't know how to date if you know
how to deal with women on a short-term
basis you're gonna suck at dealing with
women on a long term basis like it's
it's game on hard mode right so
yeah there's a lot of complexities
around that narrative
yeah well
a lot and one of those that i think
complicates things is the one of your
red flags and that's daddy issues
right
um in so many families nowadays the dads
are not present because of divorce or
whatever else is going on and so it's
feeding the cycle of
now women who don't respect the father
in the in the home and in their what
should be their frame as well
because they don't know that figure and
therefore pass that along to their kids
they're okay with the dad not being in
the picture
um
i don't know how we we stop that cycle
one
one relationship at a time that's what
what i've come to
think but
how do you have a daughter right
i have a son and a daughter and so
that's where i find your stuff really
interesting because as a mother of a son
i don't want my son to get [ __ ] over i
don't want him to go through
all of this and then all of a sudden
maybe get divorced and not have access
to his kids and be
you know run over the cold financially
um
what is the best advice that you give
that you will give your daughter down
the road
well i think daughters and sons are
different so do you want to talk about
boys first since you've got us
let's talk about boys first okay so is
this dad around
yeah well so we have them 50 50. so
we're each in there yeah so encourage
his father to spend as much time as he
can with him and do you know masculine
things teach him masculine pursuits
um boys have to learn
relationship models from their fathers
they're not going to learn from their
mother if they if they
try to learn it from the mother that's
what creates a lot of betas today right
um like single mother households are i
hate to say at their beta factories like
most kids that that come out of single
mother households the boys are quite
weak um most of the 101 consults that i
do when guys do their like batman origin
story it's always i grew up in a single
mother household either she divorced
them or he died young or something like
that but they didn't have a strong
masculine man so
that's the key thing with boys um
i think there's a great author which
women should check out if they are
mothers which is uh dr leonard sachs and
he's got quite a few books on raising
boys and girls because the model is is
very different so if you want more
resources i would go there
as far as daughters
the narrative with women is totally
different because a woman's value is
based on
her beauty right
um women want high-value successful men
yeah
strong virtuous can make it rain know
how to make money they're competent
they're not going to put up with
[ __ ] you know they can lead
they just want that kind of guy and
despite what you know the toxic feminist
narrative tells women
they can pretend to want some
uh
you know female ally that wears a pink
[ __ ] hat and marches with them on
parliament hill and wave signs about you
know like abortion right so that sort of
stuff they don't want to bang those guys
they want to bang the firefighters the
army dudes like you know the guys that
look like that right so
the thing with girls is if
you want her
to find her ideal man the key thing is
you have to constantly remind them and i
think it's it's very very tough in the
world that we live in today because
society constantly is trying to
remind women to be more promiscuous and
uh take risks that compromise their
value as they get older
a woman is concerned with a man's future
a man is concerned with a woman's past
so if she's been around the block she's
made some really bad choices uh in life
a high value guy will typically if he's
unplugged will pass on a woman like that
and you know look for somebody that's a
better mate choice over a long-term
basis
um so like there's a lot of conversation
to have but but it really just boils
down to that main thing and that's not
me saying that that's that's me
collecting evidence from evolutionary
psychologists and from a lot of very
very smart people throughout history
that have that have drawn the exact same
you know conclusion about why men and
women may select each other
it's going to be hard growing like
trying to raise a daughter and
she's going to be getting so many other
influences through social media and her
own friends and doing their own thing
how do i keep that's why i'm like how do
i keep her feminine but still
i think it's important for women to have
their own
source of income
um
i think if you're going to get into a
relationship and eventually a marriage
you should have like you're getting a
marriage license there needs to be
a prenup like that should just be
automatic it's a business
well it's two different conversations so
let's talk about marriage right because
i mean if i had a son i would tell him
not to get married if i had a daughter i
would absolutely tell her to get married
it's two totally different conversations
oh yeah 100 interesting like why would
you want to encourage your son to put
his
financial wealth at risk especially if
he's going to be successful
in an environment where
the law hates men
right well and that depends on the state
that you're in definitely right so if
you have a daughter like you want the
best for her so yeah of course you tell
her to encourage to marry the guy
hmm how does that work then then who's
she supposed to find if you encourage
the men not to well hopefully she
listens to her father and does the right
thing and you know she finds a guy kind
of like him right successful competent
you know
does like the right things in life sort
of stuff
then you tell her what you know to be
the wife to be mrs whatever you know
take his last name
um you know take the attitude and the
toxic feminism and the boss pitch stuff
and you know put in the trunk and forget
about it
okay that's interesting hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you